Chris Mannix courtside last night NBA
writer for Yahoo Sports what did you see
last night Chris well I saw a a really
resilient Boston team I mean this is now
the second time this season where they
faced the top Western Conference team
and look I'm including Oklahoma City as
a top Western Conference team even
though they're struggling on behind by
17 plus in the second half and rallied
to win this is a team did that you know
starting to players that are from
generation Z it's a team that is
incorporating all but for new players at
the mix and lost Gordon Hayward to a
crow test injury and still they play
with unbelievable resolve an
unbelievable commitment there they're an
elite defensive team and I mean that
quite literally the best defensive team
in the NBA right now and and the way
they're playing it just it's showing a
poise and a maturity that you just
couldn't expect from a team that young
in this new together yeah I like what I
saw with the defense part of it but also
you have Brown and Tatum who I don't
know if they were expecting them to be
this good this soon but they almost are
forced to be this good this soon if this
team is going to challenge in the East
but if I said right now yeah Celtics or
Cavs win the East well I'm assuming you
read my column last night damn where I
declared it the Celtics are gonna win
the East I threw it in I throw it out
there it's it's a done deal
mid November I made the call and as you
know I'm never wrong about these things
no you're no no you're not
it's it's it's a lock and I now realize
every word coming out of my mouth is
being rolled on and that's fine but yes
Boston's coming out of East would you
put a bet on that no see here's here's
the problem with my bets with you you
don't bet anything back you say to me
like hey will you shave your head if
this happens hey will you spin the way
punishments happens and me you know kind
of being sort of Charlie Brown esque I
just say yeah sure I'll do it of course
I believe that much and I get off the
phone with you and I realized that
there's no upside here for me oh we're
gonna happen to go shake terms and if
we're to have an actual bet I'll let you
host this show if you win will you sit
in Perloff seat during it yes yes I will
sit in mclogan see Wow okay no see
that's appealing now what's the now flip
side of it you have to get a haircut
that looks like paulie's I don't even
know what you say to the barber when you
go in there you just bring a picture of
Paulie
can we do it in like the month of August
sure okay yeah we could do as long as
there's like a window where I can grow
it back before I actually have to be
seen in it you know I mean right boy
then we can make it work we can make it
work all right uh a couple other things
I don't know if you read the GQ article
on Kevin Durant but man was that
fascinating was some of the quotes that
he had where he talked about how he's
not a leader
it's steps a leader he doesn't want to
be a leader the the insecurities that he
still has and he carries around with him
that he's trying to fight through it's
pretty amazing for one of the top five
players in the world did you take
anything away from that article that
profile yeah a little bit and the
leadership stuff was very much what you
would take you back but you know Kevin
if you ever around him he's just
perfectly willing at all times to kind
of open up about the stuff that's what
people love about him and what he most
often gets criticized for I don't look
if you're if you don't feel comfortable
in that leadership role then that's
great like admitting to it like opens
you up for criticism but it's great like
if you if you just want to be Kevin
Durant 28.4 game score MVP candidate who
cares not everybody
is cut out to be you know Jordan or bird
or one of these guys that love sea
craves you know that responsibility I
don't I I commend Durant in some ways
for for being willing to be kind of bear
his soul like that in in a story knowing
knowing that he probably get roundly
criticized for most people for saying
something like that talking to Chris
Mannix Yahoo Sports NBA writer joining a
stand Patrick show the Commissioner of
the NBA is trying to get rid of that one
and done what kind of what would be the
perfect plan do you think that would
placate everybody in a situation like
this well I've had over the years of a
bunch of conversations with both the
Union and the NBA now like this is a
union issue like if they've got to get
Michelle Roberts and a union on board
and give them something in exchange I
mean there has been an impasse between
these two sides for since the rule was
first implemented what 10-15 years ago
it and and Roberts to this point is
always said to me and people whom you've
always said to me that there's something
significant sent back and return I don't
know exactly what that is at this point
but there's going to have to be either a
spike in player salaries extensional
number of years there's got to be a
significant give back to the Union the
NBA would love to have a rule in place I
think a compromise might be Dan kind of
a rule where they say you can come out
after your senior year but if you go to
college it's two or three years I can
see that being a rule that they can
agree on but the only way they can agree
on it is if is if the Players Union
might actually get something in return
yeah I'm not sure where we're headed but
I think we're headed towards the end of
the one and done and probably in the
next couple years but you're right you
think it should be though like what do
you like this is my question to people
whenever this comes up like what should
it be well I don't I don't think the
one-and-done is perfect and you can't
prove a negative but I'm convinced
because I saw so many guys in the 90s
come into the draft that has no business
corleone young cosmic David I mean these
guys had
no business coming to drive I'm
convinced that as much as we think the
one-and-done is flawed probably is the
one had done is probably saved dozens if
not more of a players from themselves
forced them to go to a college where
they realize while they were there but
they weren't cut out with approach yeah
I understand that the one and done has
been a little bit of a safeguard with
some of these kids who would have come
out after high school but what if you
get drafted and your contracts
guaranteed but you don't make the roster
and you play in the G League that's a
possibility here I just think the
college has to get back to being college
you know what they've embarrassed
themselves because they acquiesced to
these kids who come in they don't want
to be there hey we'll look the other way
you don't have to go to class and we'll
rent you for six months you play the
game we play the game everybody benefits
and you know we move on happily ever
after until the next wave comes in
college has to go back to being a place
of higher education learning and not
being made fools out of I completely
agree and it is kind of a token you know
viewpoint of college but even if they
change these rules is college really
going to ever be college I mean our our
major programs not going to continue to
go out of their way to make things
easier for student athletes will will
money stop changing hands as we've seen
with this college basketball scandal it
may be it happens on a lesser scale but
I've given up believing that that
there's any hope for for college sports
ever developing into that true amateur
system that we all kind of wanted to be
I think it's always going to be a flawed
and probably corrupt system for the next
for the foreseeable future yeah yeah
probably so because there's so much
money at stake the situation with the
Lakers with Lanza ball being benched you
know the micromanaging and looking at
his shot and his confidence level and
what do you do if you're Luke Walton
with Lanza ball now what do you do coach
him up that's all you can do I mean like
you know you bench him maybe you don't
start him you don't send them to the key
league that's that's kind of a dumb
theory have seen floated out there a
little bit that means you just
keep working with him and he's in a
unique situation because of the
spotlight he's on he's under and because
of everything that his father says has
said and will probably continue to say
but a point guard struggling is not news
I mean don't look at Russell Westbrook's
numbers from his first year I think he
like was like 17 turnovers a game and I
mean he was just he was a mess as trying
to figure out the most difficult
position I think in any sport playing
point guard in the NBA because of the
complexities of it because of how
different is from the college game and
because of you know the number of
players you go up against every single
night it is unbelievably challenging now
they have to figure the jump shot thing
out I didn't like that Magic Johnson so
summarily dismissed the idea of changing
it
I mean if it's broken you got to fix it
Kawhi Leonard came into the NBA as a sub
33 point shooter sit banking with the
Spurs they said to him we need to change
your shot Kawhi did and now he's one of
the best play 3-point shooters in
basketball if they theme this jump shot
broken they've got to go to Lonzo and
he's got to be willing to change his
shot to become a better player that's
the only thing I can see as being up for
debate everything else it's just normal
Dan the playing this position being in
this spot it's just normal for a point
guard to struggle the way he is great
stuff Chris thanks for getting up for us
and we'll talk to you soon
I gotta go look at Paulie it's short
it's Jaidyn it's jason statham just
bringing a picture of jason statham only
keeps telling me it's Jason Statham
because yeah I got a Jason Statham
haircut it's like it's like Jason
Statham if he was trapped on the island
that Tom Hanks wasn't cast away for like
a couple of years thank you Chris have a
good weekend bye dad that's Chris man
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you